i'm brendan sagalow and this is answer
the internet
[Music]
would you watch a sex tape of your
number one celebrity banging your arch
anime uh
my number one celebrity is eminem and i
would love to see him bang anybody
because he's for sure autistic so i kind
of want to see how that
like i dude eminem gives off that vibe
like he would be terrible in bed
and that he's horrible with women so i
would love to see him bang my arch enemy
which is my mom
so i throw it can i just throw it
uh if you could have an endless supply
of anything what would it be
uh [ __ ] love
love i've been doing that where i stop
saying [ __ ] and i say like
love and romance because that's what i
really want so yeah i would have an
endless supply of romance if you were
stuck in any food and had to eat your
way out
what would it be [ __ ]
[Laughter]
would you have sex with a girl with no
arms um
yeah i would for sure just i mean i like
a little
this might be a little too personal but
i like a little like pre-hand job kind
of thing where they're like you know
when you're like
really getting getting making out with
somebody and they're like grabbing your
dick and everything and
so that would be kind of unless you
could i could say she can't do that
because she has normal
she starts like you know but um
no i probably wouldn't no offense to but
like
uh i would start i don't know i'd
probably find something out about myself
that i don't want like
i'd like be calling my friends like i'm
really into sucking numb the world is a
wacky place right now from the world
of sports down to movies entertainment
is not what we're used to but lebat blue
light is making sure that things stay as
normal as possible
lebat blue wants to make sure that fans
hashtag gear up
and here at answer the internet every
tuesday you can count on answer the
internet to bring you some entertainment
our featured question today from the bat
blue light enjoy it
if you were continuously getting
attacked by eagles one at a time
how many could you kill before they got
you i would
[ __ ] eagles up dude i would if they were
coming at me
because i play a lot of video games so
my my like my hand-eye coordination is
pretty top-notch
so if eagles were coming at me i think i
could take one
out i think about that all the time like
when people get attacked by dogs
i'm like i would kick a dog in the
[ __ ] face look it's
low to the ground like eagles are coming
in the only way that an eagle could get
me is probably from the back
so i think like 80 right eagles are i
mean like fast like
a true bald eagle i think is fast and i
think like they're
big if i saw it though i i've seen one
pick up a deer before
okay what are you trying to say is that
a weight
no dude this is what would happen yeah
eagles coming down if it was coming from
this angle yeah i could take an eagle
out like
like crazy if it was coming from like
there in the back coming one at a time
one at a time come yeah it's coming one
time in your field of vision how many
can you ask
uh infinity i would
i the eagle would be gone if if every
eagle on the earth was coming at me
no i'd probably be extinct i would
probably lose steam
well you know what i would throw a punch
and then their talon would like scratch
my hand
and i'd be like [ __ ] and you wouldn't
realize that that could happen so that
would probably i think i could take out
like three or four
realistically coming at me just [ __ ]
pow
if you could make your dick as big as
you wanted but for every inch you'd lose
two years of your life how big would you
make it
so you're starting from zero starting
from no dick yeah you're building a dick
it's not like you're growing on your
dick
zero inches okay so you know if you want
even just like a four inch dick that
means you're losing eight years from the
rest you know right away
eight years two two years per inch um
i would do like what about a half what's
a half so if i'm like three and a half
so it'd be one year dude you would use
yeah you would lose one year
per half inch i would do like three and
a half four i'll go four all four years
i mean four inches lose eight ears
because that's like where my dick is
now it's kind of little it's a little
bit smaller than four but i dude i was
jerking off the other day
and i this is too much and i
i i was i was like because i've always
been like oh it's not the dick i want
whatever but i was like looking at my
dick and i was like this is a good
something happened something it finally
caught up
it finally caught up with me so for four
inches and you're dead
you know what do you think that'll be
what do you think how long are you gonna
live
so i'll probably die at 32.
[Laughter]
uh if you got a one-time pass to do
whatever
you wanted what crime would you commit
um
probably a like a like a big heist i
would love to do a big casino heist or
something
to plan that oh no yeah
like a bank robbery i don't know because
all you have to do is get a gun
and everything and then like just take
out like would you get a gun
this is america baby where can she get a
gun
um yeah something where i get my oh i
know
uh i would be a cat burglar and i would
i would i would uh
uh take the uh the jewels in london
the crown jewels who was the hottest
celebrity you'd have a chance with if
they got to know you i say this every
time and it's gonna feel weird coming
out because we're both comics i
i think i could get sarah silverman i
really think
she would be into me i would be into you
sarah so
i know you know there's an age
difference here that's probably the
not a good way to start this
[Laughter]
but yeah i really i really honestly
think i could get it i could get serious
because you look like manchester jimmy
yeah
that's exactly it and i'm charming and
i'm you know there's something about me
if you could be a master at one of the
four bases of sex
but you'd have to be below average at
every other base which one would you
choose
see now your brain immediately goes to
like you want to be good
at you know fourth base or whatever
because that's what really matters
but i think whatever base is eating
eating out yeah
whatever base that is because i could go
look i'm not that good at this
and but let me get my nut and then i'm
gonna go at you like a [ __ ] like
you're like you're a denny's can i
change my answer first
first i i pride myself on being a good
kisser and maybe they can get there by
how good i am at kissing i'll
suck i'll suck your tongue dude i go i
go i bite the
i'll bite the lip for a second i i i get
told in a good kiss but i just think
everyone's lying
i i i know i don't believe no come on
i'll let let's make out right now and
i'll let you know
[Laughter]
no i you know i bite the lip i suck the
tongue a little bit
would you rather have a dog die every
time you laugh or have
there be a genocide every time you fall
in love well
i i i anybody who starts out well
look there's too many people already i
would say i fall in love a lot i have a
problem where i like i meet a girl and
i'm just
i'm just i fall in love immediately so
um yeah
i would literally become the last man on
earth if that was what she was like i
wouldn't make out with you you're the
lemon
fell in love again
deaths had skyrocketed because now
that's how many
has once again become friend-zoned so
all of africa is gone
this is fun uh would you rather never
have any buffalo sauce food
again or only be able to masturbate to
pregnant porn
whoa that one's hard because i don't eat
buffalo
i don't have buffalo sauce on anything
i love cheeseburgers okay no more
cheeseburgers no more cheeseburgers or
only masturbate to
uh no more cheeseburgers because i'd be
skinny
i would i never feel good after a
cheeseburger i eat it and i just want to
[ __ ] kill myself so
i would rather uh and i can't do
pregnancy pregnant
it's gro pregnancy is gross i'm sorry
you know
some i get yelled at by some of my
pregnant friends about that but
pregnancy
is uh it's gross you got a baby in there
it's peeing in you i don't like it
uh would you rather live your life as is
or be a billionaire but you have to blow
a dude every day
uh i'm blowing the dude okay
you know it's i i always hate when like
the questions that are like would you
blow a guy because everybody you know
some
you know more than half of people in the
world blow people and i think
i could get used to that to completion
yeah that's fine
that's okay that's all right you know in
in certain cultures they take [ __ ] and
they rub it on their face and everything
for skin you don't have to do that i
mean you can if you want
yeah you know you make the best out of
it you wake up every morning though
and like again i'm with you i'm doing it
yeah but you wake up every morning and
it's just a fully recommend standing
there where it's like
before you know get out of bed you gotta
suck that he's writing a check he's like
who am i making this out
to it could be me literally
i think it's better that it's every day
yeah you get used to it
yeah it's like if it's one time it's
like i don't want to suck this i don't
wanna
i wanna dig but if it's like here's a
billion dollars just gonna do this thing
every day
well this is only one this is only the
first time yeah i mean
the first uh the first couple of times
would be rough but then it just becomes
a timing issue you're like i [ __ ] i
i gotta get up 15 minutes but it will
get you up you know i have a hard time
waking up so if i know i have a long day
ahead of me
plus i have to suck a dude's dick i'm
like get up at six i'm like kevin hart i
get up at six or three
i get up at three a.m suck a dick go out
for a jog
you know and then yeah that's it
thanks for having me this is so much fun
that was great
you